all right we're filming are you sure I
have to strategically hide from the
audience that I split my pants with
should we have better audio or do you
think that'll work anyway and this year
she's here for this this moment to say
hi Anna alright so today we all the
heater turned on now our sound is ruined
that's not the only thing that's been
ruined you mean my pants damn you know
my joke this is why she makes the big
box and you don't if you're wondering
why we're here today it's because I
recently received a package in the mail
guess what gang we finally made it is
there good contrast between my hair and
this curtain or does it look like
guess what gang we made it we got to the
the button I had to really hassle
YouTube to send this to me because they
forgot and I believe that Anna had a
role in that yes she would kept yelling
at me to get in touch with the the
customer service people and ask because
I was like oh sure I'll send it
eventually and two months passed so 100
cases it's been at a hundred and 3k for
like like seven or eight weeks now and
it won't tick up or down no matter what
I do I feel like something's wrong and
I'm a little paranoid now subscribe to
consciously realistic you should
actually this is my buddy David if you
don't recognize him already he's been in
a bajillion videos on the channel
including podcasts he's helped me filmed
a lot a film a lot of the live-action
stuff so anyway today we're gonna
celebrate our victory is a channel me
and my fiance and this this bearded
weirdo hippy man and also you the
100,000 people that made this possible
we're gonna open it with this scary
rusty pair of scissors that I found in
my
basement for everybody who subscribes
this you all area scissors hey I'm
trying to congratulate your audience for
being wonderful people and here you are
just being a greedy jerk oh but wanting
to open your thing all of you who
subscribed you're wonderful people and
we appreciate all your viewership yeah
use the scariest pair of scissors you
can find for these sorts of things
use the rustiest the ones that are most
likely to cause you to get infected and
you'll need to get your tetanus shots if
you ever make it contact your skin cut
away from yourself that's the rule right
oh did we do it hello bro a black piece
of sky alright I'm gonna hang this up on
my wall and just occasionally just give
it a good glance over yeah look at that
you've you've just done something that
very few youtubers accomplished you had
an astonishing 100,000 people subscribed
to your channel
we know that youtubers can get really
big but we hope that you don't lose
sight of the reality behind the
six-digit milestone each person who's
subscribed to your channel has been
touched by what you created they were
inspired challenged or entertain unless
you're like a bot that just posts
Spiderman Elsa videos you achieve this
milestone with hard work perseverance a
lot of crying and probably a healthy
sense of humor to my sense of humor you
really need to think about how many
self-deprecating jokes you make and how
that affects your self-esteem you loser
sofas team what's that oh look is low
authentication for the piece de
resistance
yeah these look different here's some
wet-naps in here to wash it down I
thought those were silica gel packs that
you could eat yeah sure guardzilla
Mendoza and to think around 5000 subs I
thought maybe I should change that name
and then I was too lazy to do it now
here it is anyway recognize your team
share the recognition by allowing your
team to purchase a personalized creator
work I don't know what this means my
team like like you guys and Ben and
Scott you're not so naive
yeah it's give it good old give it a
little rub hi Anna
look at it we did it specifically you
did it by yelling at me to get this
because I was probably not gonna ask
them otherwise thank you for supporting
me and pushing me to make more videos
and just being the greatest soul little
lady I've ever seen and I love you a lot
and hopefully when we have the diamond
won or whatever comes next the gold one
whichever the [ __ ] we'll be able to sit
here on my lap like I'm Santa Claus
because you're so small that gives a
whole new meaning to the term here comes
Santa Claus thank you guys for your
contributions to this and and helping me
reach this glorious milestone and I hope
you're all around for the next one and I
hope we can meet the impossible
milestone of 104 thousand subs because
I've been stuck for so long please God
just recommend the videos to your
friends I don't care you have to do
please thank you and I love you a lot
and we're worried about you right now
and you will see you soon and
make sure by your limp air Rusty's to
this video sponsored by rust scissor
legends and where you buy a pair of
rusty scissors and then you get you get
infected and you need to cut your hair
then you get tetanus and then you get
all sick